Salut ! Dans quelques secondes vous allez voir une vidéo qui va parler de mathématiques.
Comme ça si vous voulez fuir... c'est maintenant.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui on va se faire une petite astuce  mathématiques des familles !
Ca fait plaisir !
Ce qui est intéressant c'est que ça va être à la fois une astuce de maths, oui, mais aussi de manière de bluffer les gens si vous voulez.
C'est à vous d'en faire ce que vous voulez au final !
Puisque dans quelques minutes, vous serez capable d'extraire une racine cubique de tête.
Générique !
[musique]
Vous allez demander à quelqu'un de choisi un nombre à 2 chiffres dans sa tête. Il choisi un nombre à 2 chiffres.
Avec une calculatrice ou avec son téléphone, il multiplie ce chiffre par lui même une fois et une seconde fois.
Ainsi il a le cube de son chiffre de départ.
Il vous donne le cube, et vous en quelques secondes à peine, vous êtes capable de retrouver le chiffre originel, puisque vous savez extraire une racine cubique !
Je veux dire... qui ne sait pas extraire une racine cubique ?!
Le pire c'est que c'est simple à faire, c'est encore plus simple que pour les carrés.
On avait déjà fait une vidéo sur extraire une carré mentalement. Le cube c'est beaucoup plus simple.
Vous avez simplement 10 choses à retenir.
Alors évidemment, vous pouvez les écrire quelque part, les noter ou faire une antisèche, mais je vous recommande de les apprendre une bonne fois pour toute.
On a vu assez de techniques de mémoire cette année ou de visualisation pour retenir ça.
Ce que vous devez retenir, et je me mets sur le coté pour vous le noter en même temps...
C'est que le cube de 0 c'est 0.
Le cube de 1 c'est 1.
Le cube de 2 c'est 8.
Le cube de 3 c'est 27.
Le cube de 4 c'est 64.
Le cube de 5 c'est 125.
Le cube de 6 c'est 216.
Le cube de 7 c'est 343.
Le cube de 8 c'est 512.
Et le cube de 9 c'est 729.
Une fois que vous savez ça, vous savez extraire une racine cubique !
Donc la personne à qui vous allez demander de penser à un nombre à deux chiffres et qu'il l'a multiplié deux fois par son propre chiffre,
en clair qui à fait le cube de ce chiffre, vous donne un résultat.
C'est un résultat à 5 ou 6 chiffres.
Prenons par exemple, 39 304.
"39 304", c'est 5 chiffres.
A chaque fois vous allez séparer en deux pour avoir 2 lots.
Les 3 derniers et les 2 ou 3 premiers.
D'abord on s’intéresse aux 2 ou 3 premiers.
Ici c'est 39.
Ce sont les deux premiers, mais dans ma tête c'est "039", avec le 0 j'ai trois premiers chiffres.
Je ne suis pas sur d’être toujours clair mais je suis sur que vous comprenez.
Vous cherchez dans votre tableau que vous avez écrit ou appris où est-ce que s'insère votre résultat.
Et moi 39, je sais que c'est entre 27 et 64, donc le premier chiffre de la racine cubique sera soit un 3 soit un 4.
Puisque 39 est situé entre 27 et 64.
Et vous prenez le plus petit des deux, puisque l'autre il dépasserait.
Donc je sais que ça commence par un 3.
Et pour le chiffre des unités ça va être encore plus simple de le trouver.
Vous prenez les trois derniers. Donc ici "304" et même encore plus simple, vous prenez juste l'unité de ces trois derniers, donc ici le 4.
Et vous cherchez dans le tableau quel cube fini par 4.
Il n'y en a pas deux qui finissent sur la même chose sur les dix.
Et le seul qui fini par 4, c'est celui de 4, soit 64.
Donc je sais que l'unité sera 4.
Donc le résultat c'est 34.
La racine cubique de 34 304, c'est 34.
Un peu comme l'age que je vais avoir dans quelques jours...
On ne se moque pas de mon age !
Je vous rappelle la méthode très rapide.
Vous demandez à quelqu'un de penser à un nombre à 2 chiffres, de faire le cube de ce nombre et de vous le donner.
Vous prenez, vous, les deux ou trois premiers. Vous cherchez dans votre tableau où est-ce qu'il s'insère entre deux résultats,
un proche en dessous, un proche au dessus,
et vous prenez le plus petit des deux pour avoir le chiffre des dizaines.
Pour celui des unités, vous prenez l'unité du cube qu'on vient de vous donner et vous cherchez dans votre tableau le cube qui fini par cette même unité la.
Essayez de le faire, vous allez voir. Je vous l'ai dis, c'est encore plus simple que d'extraire une racine carrée !
Si vous n’êtes pas super chaud pour l'apprendre dès aujourd'hui par cœur, notez le au moins dans votre téléphone, dans "notes", dans quelque chose.
Vous pourrez le faire avec ça à l'appui et ça va vous entrainer à le faire de temps en temps.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ! J'espère que ça vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air, c'est très important.
N'oubliez pas également que vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaine en cliquant ici ou alors par ici.
Parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre ! Et ouais !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]